hello everybody my name's lloyd
essler i've always had a bit of an
interest in cemeteries and
dead things and interesting stories
around early south and and if you want
to come along
to the eastern cemetery 6 30 on
the 4th of november having a bit of a
walk around here for
about an hour and looking at some of the
interesting graves
and a few of the stories from some of
the southern pioneers so
everybody welcome to come along to that
we're just standing beside a grave here
this is the
mcnab grave and
uh one of the early ones here so it's
alexander and janet mcnabb but the
the um this is the tomb also of robert
mcnabb who is a member of parliament
and uh well known as the author
of a couple of very important books on
south and one of them is the old whaling
days
and murie heku which was very valuable
bit of
early research robert was the
survivor of a family
he was the oldest child while he was
away at school
um this is in 1871 all his siblings died
they caught a disease and within a few
days there was
there's four four or five children all
died so he ended up being the only child
one of the tragedies of the
early years but not particularly
uncommon because medical
practice was a bit primitive there were
lots of
dangerous things a lot of people got
drowned in those days and of course
there was infectious diseases so
um glad we got one survivor out of the
mcnabb family to make a contribution to
south and history